these are the bones of ice age mammoths
the largest
land mammals to ever set foot on the
american continent
they're seeing the light of day for the
first time in more than 20
000 years animal remains from the
pleistocene era were first discovered in
this part of mexico in the 1970s but
archaeologists say those previous
discoveries pale in comparison
we're happy because we're documenting
the variety of flora and fauna that once
thrived here
just in this area we recently found a
tooth fragment belonging to a
saber-toothed tiger
it may have broken off during an
encounter with a mammoth
restoration and cataloging is tedious
work and a delicate touch is crucial
the bones are quite brittle after
spending several millennia under the
dirt
a chemical solution is sprayed to help
preserve the integrity of
every fragment no matter how small
lourdes san agustin has been working at
this dig site for three months
today she's carefully piecing together a
pelvic bone that once belonged to an
american camel
lourdes is one of dozens of restoration
workers who have been specially trained
for this massive archaeological project
for many here it's a once-in-a-lifetime
experience
i never imagined i would be doing
something like this working with bones
when i go home my family always asks
what we discovered today
it's a very cool experience
the first discoveries at this site were
made last year when construction workers
broke ground for a new airport at a
military base just outside mexico city
today a first of its kind partnership
between scientists and the mexican
military has led to the cataloging of
hundreds of individual specimens
the military's high command has
instructed us to provide all the
supports investigators need
we supply resources like laser scanners
land surveys
drone flights anything that's needed for
the study
a year on there are now 230 gig sites
just like this one
and the teams say there's still plenty
more to find as you can see we are
completely surrounded by the bones of
ice age mammals just in this area alone
where we're standing
there are at least two sets of mammoth
tusks but there's also the remains of
giant sloths
saber-toothed tigers and many other
species that have been extinct
for thousands of years once a specimen
has been cleaned cataloged and
reinforced it's prepared for transport
scientists and government officials say
the plan is to showcase the assembled
skeletons at a museum
inside the mexican capital's newest
airport scheduled for completion
in 2022 manuel rapalo al jazeera
mexico city